[Music]
at Texas Aven and exotic hospital
there's cuteness do you want to get some
food around every corner Dr
th turn around oh my God I thought I
heard something oh they're cute
oh they're really
cute I walk on the treatment to start my
day and the first thing I see are two
adorable baby
raccoons these sweet little raccoons are
so brand new that their eyes aren't even
open yet I love the noises they're so
cute the rehab are supposed to come pick
them up oh good okay the baby raccoons
were found abandoned in an apartment
complex overnight and were rushed to the
emergency hospital but the ER staff
hasn't been able to get them to eat she
said they wouldn't suckle and they've
been there for at least 12 hours are
they really well hydrated yeah they seem
pretty well hydrated they do the baby
raccoons don't seem to be dehydrated but
they haven't eaten anything since they
arrived at the ER so in this instance
we're going to mix up some puppy formula
so we can give them a good meal before
they go off to the rehabilitator food
and swallow that I
[Music]
know since they wouldn't suckle we're
going to just put it in the tummy for
them let feel feels like a good warm
tummy baby raccoons this young have to
eat every few hours to keep up their
blood sugar and hold off starvation you
want to do the next one although I love
raccoons and have kind of secretly
always wanted one as a pet I know that
these baby raccoons they're wild animals
and they just don't make good pets and
so I'm really happy I get to work with
them here so I can make sure that they
get a good chance in life to be able to
go to the rehabilitator and get released
back into the wild where they belong the
baby raccoons will stay safe in the ER
until the wildlife rehab Picks Them
[Music]
Up the cuteness continues with a prickly
little patient brought in by the local
Hedgehog
rescue hey guys so who do we have today
uh Miss de Miss Dei we noticed she
yesterday that her snout is kind of
swollen here on the sides and then this
one kind of puffed up a little bit the
night before I had picked her up and I
was holding her and I noticed that
across the bridge of her nose was kind
of swollen so I wasn't sure if it was
like a sinus infection starting how old
is she 5 years 2 months she old you all
older hedgehogs yes Miss Dei is a
5-year-old Hedgehog and hedgehogs do
only live about 5 to 7 years so Miss D
is definitely a senior citizen she's the
oldest and and the old ones are the ones
that I worry about the most because they
have a harder time fighting everything
absolutely yes Miss Dei is just one of
the dozens of hedgehogs cared for by the
Hedgehogs of
Texas we started a hedgehog rescue
because there's so many out there that
need the help I started with one and
then it went from one to two and then it
went from two to four and now I have 30
something
oh no Miss D can I put this here she
doesn't want to bite me no she a good
girl Miss Dee is pretty laidback she
likes a little bit of attention but not
too much cuz you know she's an older
lady so she gets a little bit cranky
like most hedgehogs do on baby girl
you're being very good can you just a
little bit more for me I think everyone
loves hedgehogs because they're really
really adorable but there's a lot of
things to consider about getting a
hedgehog as a pet first they're
nocturnal so you really need a lifestyle
where we're going to be kind of up when
they are they also can get kind of
grumpy uh especially when they're at the
vet be great if she let me look at her
mouth you think if you held her I could
take a Q-tip and pull up for gums yes
ready
yeah come on let me have your nose there
we
go yeah she has a lot of swelling at
this Ginga okay I can't say the tooth's
just out down to right rotten but it
definitely warant investigation
okay taking a look at Deee and just
doing a really good physical she
definitely has dental disease so I'm
thinking toothrot abscess is at the very
top of our list and it very least needs
to be ruled
out I'm sorry can I see your teeth
please oh thank you so I would say she
needs x-rays me trying to take X-rays of
a hedgehog it's probably not going to be
that helpful um with that big x-ray
machine I really want to use Dental
x-ray so that way I can just take the
little plate and take just the x-rays of
the teeth I want so I'm going to take
Dei to see Holly who's in dentistry he's
going to be able to take our dental
X-rays for us one of the many benefits
of being in this multip specialty
practice we have these two bumps on its
gums here and
here oh I see those teeth are tiny
they're the size smaller than like
pencil let we are the only practice here
that has small enough sensor that can
fit into that tiny mouth give it just 20
seconds one okay even though the digital
sensor plate is small it's as small as
it's going to get they don't make them
any smaller so we had to push it back as
far as the patient could tolerate
it let's see what that looks like okay
ready Mark
cassette go ahead and let him have his
is that is that obsessy is that where is
absy to me taking a look at these x-rays
it's pretty obvious that she definitely
has um some Blackness surrounding the
tooth which would be where an abscess is
so I really think the best thing to do
is just to move forward and see if we
can extract those teeth I don't think
that's going to be easy so we should
make it really planned once we get back
to treatment I want to take a look at
the teeth and make a plan whether we'll
actually schedule a surgery or just move
forward with immediate extraction either
way I'm 100% confident that these teeth
are the source of
[Music]
infection
up next is Sammy a 28-year-old timna
African gray who's been scratching at a
strange scabby mass under her
throat Sammy has a growth on her neck
and I had to bring the doctors look at
and see if it can be removed you're
precious I've had her for 28 years oh I
love her better than
anything what's it on diet wise oh seeds
it's on a parrot blend and whatever else
she wants yesterday she had potatoes and
red beans and ham she loves her mashed
potatoes
yes lovely get back in your cage her
favorite people food is
pizza are we don't to tell the doctor
about
that hello how's it going hi I'm Dr th
nice to meet you to meet you hello Sammy
and I know you're here because there's
something on his neck that everyone's
pretty concerned about hi oh my goodness
I do see that let's come out you
friendly you are well that's lovely
hello Sammy is a Tima African gray and
one of my personal favorite birds and
arguably one of the smartest birds in
the world to own one of these guys you
have to be extremely dedicated this
woman sits at home with her bird all day
long so so she may be actually
okay but what is not okay is that crusty
growth on Sammy's neck how are you
otherwise she's healthy as can be yeah
good very good sweetheart I know you
want to go to your mama the thing is
though is I like you and I want to hold
you Samy doesn't usually take to
strangers what what no I can't she'd
rather be with me than anybody else
sweetheart I know Sammy I just need to
take a look at this here thing I'm
looking at the lesion and it's really
ulcerative it has this big scab on it
and the scab is even kind of breaking in
some spots making uh the poor girl bleed
a little bit she is just animal this
looks infectious or potentially some
kind of vitamin deficiency that could be
caused by sami's table food diet but at
the same time it's so open that I really
want to make sure I submit this for
biopsy just in case it's a
tumor
this could be a lot of different things
it definitely could be a tumor or
something Advanced but birds can
sometimes get these it's called a
granuloma so it's basically um formation
of like pus and scar tissue and things
like that that can happen right here in
this location as a consequence of a
vitamin A deficiency but you know like I
said this can be anything so the most
important thing is when we get it off we
bi UPS see it so at this point today I
just want to make sure you know because
I have to antizer to take this thing off
um that she's healthy like really really
healthy even on the inside and so I
think her first step would be to start
with some basic blood work just make
sure she's healthy bird um and then from
there we can say Okay surgically
speaking what can we do the best
possible outcome for this is for them to
take that off her throat and and for her
to be healthy the worst possible outcome
would be for her to
die it makes me want to cry to think
about her die and I just can't stand
that so I'm going to still see I cannot
believe how she's going to stranger
she's doing good I can't believe how
she's going to Strang she'd rather be
with you but she's where it going oh my
goodness Simmy must know I'm about to do
a blood draw because she has no interest
in leaving her mother and coming to me
her Wednesday oh she go again oh okay
don't worry I'll take her quicker this
you're going to get back in your cage
come here sweetart you're going to get
back in
get back I'm going to steal her right
real quick okay
bye so today she's just we want to make
sure she's healthy do some basic blood
workor on her and then she'll come back
another day for surgery to remove the
growth and take a biopsy to make sure
that we know exactly what's going
[Music]
on back in treatment Miss Dee is coming
out of her anesthesia can we just do a
better oral exam but before she's fully
awake
Dr T takes a closer look at her
abscessed
tooth well we took some X-rays off her
teeth and obviously it's not the easiest
task because she's has a really small
mouth now I'm just taking some time to
just do a really good oral exam so I
think she's going to have to have
somebody these teeth
cooled oh it's really really loose I can
totally take that out the tooth is so
loose there's no time to schedule a
dental procedure Miss de's tooth has to
come out now
I was going to make her weight just so
it was more planned but honestly it's so
loose that I think we should just go
ahead and and take it out so what we're
going to do is we're going to put this
mouth gag and this little hedgehog to
hold it open while I try to remove this
tooth okay so hopefully this is going to
be easy but basically their teeth are
really really cool they look like people
teeth and they have like the tricuspid
root so you don't want to break it is
the
point so what I'm doing is I'm just
freeing up each of the ligaments to this
tooth when extracting thees tooth it's
really important that we extract the
entire tooth because sometimes a little
bit of a tooth root can get stuck in the
socket and that can be a source of
chronic infection so it's really
important that I get it all out in one
piece okay ready this is the
moment
Miss Dei a rescued Hedgehog has a tiny
infected tooth that must come out so
hopefully this is going to be
easy ready this is the
moment Hedgehog teeth are really really
small the mullers are definitely smaller
than a pencil eraser and The Insider
smaller than the
tip and that makes it really hard to
extract
that's it it's my little
tiny HG chog cutest tooth ever I
extracted the first tooth and thank
goodness it came out really quite easily
but I noticed that the tooth in front of
it started moving just as much and
probably is just as much of a problem of
the abscess just based upon the location
so we're going to go ahead and take that
guy to a second tooth's almost
out that's it
so probably comment of those two was
causing the visible bump that we're
seeing definitely worth it I can promise
you she's not going to miss those Wiggly
teeth because she can't even use them
anyways cuz they don't even sit still in
her mouth long enough to chew
something I have
Miss at this point I'm sending Miss Dee
home on some antibiotics and also some
good pain medications and a instructions
to be on a soft diet for the next couple
days but I'm thinking that the owner are
going to see the results pretty quickly
with her because I'm sure she's just
thankful to have those RW teeth gone
thanks guys thank you bye bye bye Miss
Dee Miss Dee will recover at home with
all of the other hedgehogs in her
Hedgehog
rescue they're sweet little spiky balls
of
[Music]
Love Sammy a 28-year-old timna African
gray is doing her best to avoid a blood
draw why do you hate me I just SCP you
did I hear someone say I got poop on my
back again the blood work is needed to
determine whether Sammy is healthy
enough to go under
anesthesia to remove a potentially
cancerous growth from her
neck nails are sharp I know S I know it
hurts I'm so sorry
right now we're just getting us a blood
sample to make sure that she is really
healthy um because I'm talking about
anesthetizing a 28-year-old bird and
that doesn't come without risk go ahead
hold off sorry I'm doing a blood draw on
Sammy to make sure that she's healthy
enough to move forward with a surgery
because the more I'm looking at this
Mass on her neck I'm actually worried it
could be potentially cancer I'm so sorry
sweetie I just don't think that's going
to heal and so it's really important
that we take her to surgery to get it
off but that's going to require
anesthesia and we want to make sure
she's as healthy as
possible I'll have results definitely by
Wednesday but I'm going to go ahead and
schedule you for
Wednesday okay yeah the reason why the
more I'm looking at this I just don't
think it's going to resolve by any kind
of medicating it topically anything like
that plus we really need that biopsy to
make sure it's not something that's
scary or cancer or something like that I
say spare no expense I want her taking
care of are you ready to go
home are you ready to go talk to
somebody about money it's a good thing
we got a credit card huh that's why
we're down here right
now I I love her better than
life she's going to she's going to get
well say
[Music]
byebye
stoy a Russian tortoise on the go can't
seem to get his bowel moving I got stoie
from my brother about 5 months ago he's
been having some poo issues or lack of
poo issues shall we
say H's on the ground so I need to be
careful yeah I was watching where he was
Dr de nice to meet you good to meet you
Sharon Slater so I know stoy cute name
by the way thank you is
five I rescued him from my brother I
love how you said you rescued him from
your brother
yeah he was kept outside all of the time
which is okay but when it gets cold you
have to bring him inside so my brother
was just keeping him in a
box he was eating really really well and
pooping I changed to Coconut core um
about a month ago that's when the issue
started and I've just not seen a lot
poop you seeing a lot of food intake or
just both less than before okay one of
the reasons suy may not be eating as
much cuz he could have ingested some of
the coconut fibers in his tank but I
won't know for sure until I do a
thorough physical exam and probably some
x-rays good well he looks like he's he's
a great body condition um he puts his
head in great and um his eyes are bright
his nails are the normal length he's
really really active isn't he I bet is
ENT he's extremely fast st's very active
he's very personable I would have never
thought a tortoise would have a
personality but he truly
does so I mean the decreased appetite
and the decreased Suffocation um these
guys are notorious for eating some of
that coconut fiber okay I honestly I
would take an x-ray um just to to see if
there's anything obvious okay um did you
happen to bring me a feal
sample that's okay what we can do is I
might just piss him off enough you might
just
go um if he doesn't that could be cuz I
haven't seen any poop in at least three
days so I know this guy's got poop yeah
so let's just take some pictures of him
look at his gastrointestinal tractor and
get some get some ideas make sure he's
doing okay sounds good okie dokie I'll
be right all right the X-ray should show
if stoy has a blockage caused by eating
some of his coconut core bedding then I
was thinking after his x-rays we can
soak them in some more water um because
I would love a feal sample on them but
she doesn't have any poop
like a little baby they like to poop in
their bath I guess the water stimulates
them I'm also going to run a feal exam
yay because a lot of the times rtil will
get parasites and that can really upset
their stomach make them not want to eat
as much will you look at your turtle
x-ray see if that's okay taking a look
at so's x-rays everything looks pretty
good there's no gas in his intestines
that would indicate an obstruction his
bone quality looks amazing which is
usually good news but in sto's case we
just still don't know why he's not
pooping stoy is my first reptile rescue
I have never rescued a tortoise before
this is the first so stoy and I are
learning as we go
oh stoy is loaded with flatulates that's
it so that's why he doesn't feel good
flagellates are a common parasite found
in tortoises that in high numbers can
make the tortoise sick T's looking at
the poop and she is impressed by the
number of all over that slide
loaded cuz look look in
there so I'm pretty sure that that's why
he's really not feeling well he just has
a way overpopulation of these parasites
called flatulates
because I know the flagus are causing
this problem it's really important that
I get the medication to treat it into
the tortoise 100%
so in order to do that it's an oral
medication so I have to put it in his
mouth I might have to wait for an
assistant I can't hold you out which
seems like really easy except when
you're working with a
tortoise who can completely put his head
all the way inside his shell he knows he
he's not stupid all right buddy I'm
sorry I'm really sorry tortoises have
like super un natural strength I mean I
can't even get my fingers behind his
head and he's not stupid and so he's
like refusing to come out I have to try
to battle with this little tiny animal
get its head out and give it the
medicine it needs to hopefully make it
feel better you just want to like grab
his head or
[Music]
something stoly a 5-year-old Russian
tortoise is hiding in his shell
tired yeah that's the thing about
Tauruses they never get tired and
refusing to take a medication to treat
parasites that are making him sick the
one problem with his treatment protocol
is that the medication is oral which
means I need his head so if I can't get
his head he's not going to get treated
so that's pretty much why I need his
head out like it's the number one factor
here so what I do is I take a little
instrument and very ever so carefully
put even traction on the little beak so
I can try to lift his little head out
just enough I can put my fingers behind
it then I can extend his neck and give
him his
medication aha yeah it got you little
guy
okay
yeah back out yeah I'm going kind just
kind of go on the side as
well
so success we were able to finally get
the medication into
stoy all
right I got it done so just repeat that
in 10 days 10 days yeah sorry I was
looking for it the first dose of the
antiparasitic medication is the most
important and since I know that Su got
his entire medication dose he should
start feeling better soon I don't even
want to know what you have to do to get
him to open it it was not easy so is
going to need a second dose of
medication but I'm thinking if so's Mom
puts it on his favorite flow he'll eat
enough of it that it'll do the trick
thank y'all so much you're welcome have
a good night you know I feel really good
about the diagnosis I'm glad it's not
something worst like a blockage of some
type I'm just leaving here wondering how
I'm going to get that medicine down him
I'm hoping he'll take it on a dandelion
flower which is his
favorite
the results of the blood work on Sammy
the timna African gray are back and show
that Sammy is healthy enough to go under
anesthesia to remove the strange and
potentially cancerous growth from her
neck what is that it's a barnacle so the
purpose of this procedure is to biopsy
what's going on so we don't know what
this is it could be nutritional it could
be an infection or it could be a tumor
and so we just really need to figure out
what it is and that's why we're doing
the surgery timna African grays can live
into their 50s so at 28 Sammy is a
middle-aged bird even with clean blood
work putting her under carries some risk
yeah I'm scared to death that she's that
something bad's going to happen to her
you know I I just couldn't bear
that she has been my best friend for a
long time she's such a
sweetheart because the mass on Samy's
neck could be cancerous it's important
that not a single cell of the abnormal
growth is Left
Behind so I'm just carefully cutting the
skin around and then what we're going to
do is very easy blunt dissection to try
to get cuz it actually Dives deep in
underneath the
skin whenever you have a tumor even if
it's not metastatic meaning it's going
to spread everywhere it really has to be
removed completely because leaving even
a few cancer cells behind could cause a
tumor to regrow right in that area
[Music]
again there's not a whole lot I can do I
just I just just have to sit and wait
and see what's going to
happen I'm just putting on my faith in
the
bed cool okay it's
off and we're going to send that to a
laboratory to make sure it's not a
tumor and we'll at the very least get
answers I think I mean instantly getting
her some relief is going to be really
nice oh you're waken you're wakey wakey
e and bakey I'm
sorry
[Music]
Sammy is still coming out of
anesthesia but she is stable enough to
have a visitor she's doing good right
yeah she can't go home yet oh Well I
know that but she's doing good you want
to come see her yeah oh yes can I go see
her oh want to see your bird friend too
oh hiy baby
girl so your mom is right here hey baby
girl
oh oh hi I don't usually bring owners
back to see their Birds right right
after surgery while they're recovering
but Samy's mom was so worried that I
wanted to show her so far she's doing
okay so at this point I just need her to
get on her feet be less groggy and
she'll get to go home oh I'm going to
wait for her try to wait for her anyway
the doctor said that she might be able
to come home this afternoon so we're
going to wait and and see that's what
I'm looking for for the end of the day
all right Sammy she she'll be back for
you don't worry by nor You Be Good
Girl by the end of the day Sammy the
timna African gray is awake enough to go
home you're going to bite me following
surgery to remove a potentially
cancerous growth can I see your incision
so Sammy is doing amazing I was actually
just about to send her home but she
keeps scratching her neck and I don't
want her incision to bleed or
potentially I have to redo a surgery so
I'm just kind of putting a little
bandaid bit a Band-Aid over the incision
so that way we don't have any problems
pretty I did it really super loose okay
okay I'mma to put you down don't be
crazy I'm sorry are you
broken but you look all
cute what
[Music]
happened
there she is there she is she has a
fashionable color cuz she kept itching
her
incision so it should be no
problem um do the same bab yeah see what
she was doing that's what she was doing
so I didn't want her to accidentally cut
it open but that should at least
help I know I miss you too yes I did I
did yes Mama missed you and I want to
see the incision in 5 days just to make
sure everything looks okay okay and I
can take the stitches out in 2 weeks
yeah hopefully by the time she comes
back for her recheck I'll have the
results of the
biopsy thanks so much by thank you can
you open the door there you go good boy
I'm thrilled to death to get to take her
home I may sit up with her all night
with her in my
lap a new day at Texas Aven and exotic
hospital brings in an orphan dep possum
in need of care so this little guy came
to us from a Good Samaritan just found
him um out on the streets so we're going
to get him
rehydrated give him some food open your
mouth and then we'll send him to the
rehabber that will fix him up and then
re-release him to the
wild the busy morning rolls on with a
turkey of a case that comes from one of
Dr T's colleagues at the clinic good
morning morning how are you good there
are you Dr mmed from internal medicine
needs help with her aggressive pet
turkey named Jim that keeps attacking
her husband I have these wonderful pet
turkeys which sounds crazy in of itself
but they're not treating my husband very
well it's this one and he's only
aggressive to my husband and Men you
want to see a video it's it's a little
embarrassing the
what oh my
gosh I've seen turkeys be aggressive
before but nothing like
this I don't want to make it a situation
where that's turkey versus husband I
think he might win out but you never
know as funny as that video is it's
actually a really serious situation I
mean a turkey acting that aggressive
isn't safe for the person and it's
certainly not safe for the
turkey so we're off to Dr melman's place
to have a
look as time and I pull up in the drive
we're seeing quite a collection of
animals right off the bat there's a
horse there's several pekkas and then as
I'm driving up there are our two
patients Dwight and Jim just running
alongside I think they're excited to see
me oh my that that's them that's the
badly behaved ones yes oh they're so
look at them display you looking sexy
men you want to walk in and we can go
see them Let's Take a Look So the plan
Dr th as I would like her to see what's
happening not that I'm trying to get you
attacked but so she can see what's going
to happen and then we'll talk about a
plan about what we want to do to help
with
that the dark one is
Dwight gray one is Jim that's the one
that's giving us a problem yes well
let's um let's use you as bait sir step
right up and let's uh get a turkey over
here
okay so my plan today is to see these
guys in their natural environment and I
would really like to see exactly what's
happening to poor David to make them be
so
aggressive there he goes oh he was Jing
out he takes cheap shots so he goes when
you go away from him see watch he might
do it they're usually out in the pasture
and they'll see me come out and they'll
both stop and they'll watch
me and they'll they'll slowly kind of
meander their way up and they check to
see if I have my stick or not and if I
have my stick they keep their distance
but some times I go out there
bare-handed without a
stick and that's when he comes and
attacks
[Music]
me see I
[Laughter]
know Dr T is at her colleague Dr melm
Med's Farm that's them that's the to see
if she can help with an aggressive pet
turkey named
Jim who keeps attacking Dr mad's
husband
I
know okay part of me was like okay how
bad can it be it's a turkey can it
doesn't bite you no but they fling
themselves I mean it's full on weight
like it'll land on a stack it's the
height that I'm wor about it's going to
get him in the face you oh boy got you
are you really okay what was it that
hurt you was it his he went right for
the grow in
that go if I was David I'd be actually
really
scared um it's it's a really big bird it
launches its entire body hurls up at the
guy and and takes some pretty cheap
shots we got to figure something out
here okay honey we're going to take you
down a couple pegs with some
implants observing Jim it's clear to me
that he's a very dominant male turkey oh
boy think don't turn your back do not
turn your back in fact he's so dominant
that he could have an overabundance of
testosterone I'm going to inject Jim
with an implant that's going to reduce
his testosterone there's been
Publications that this implant will
hopefully help with the aggression Dr
melet how are we going to um collect him
oh towards us towards us so I think if
we can get him in a corner then I think
we can just do it on the ground don't
you think oh yeah yeah
yeah okay you're out of the picture cuz
you're upsetting him okay no antagonize
the turkey see how we
sweet nothing's
happening I know I actually can't
believe how easy it is Tanya's pretty
effortlessly just holding Jim while Dr
melin and I are trying to get a good
look at him and decide where we're going
to be able to put the
implant chest is he actually pretty
docile too in most
ways it's kind of crazy to think about
how he just attacked somebody not even
two minutes
ago okay ready sh one two three oh my
gosh I know big guy I know I know and
then I'm coming out
and that's it good
boy he didn't even
Flinch that's it no I want to hold
[Music]
him so our game plan for now is just to
see how the behavior is with just one
implant and then we can make a decision
to get together if whether I need to do
more implants or David just needs to
carry a bigger stick I mean what did
Roosevelt say walk softly and softly and
carry a big S that's going to be you
man all I can tell you I'm the only
person in this family who has no
problems eating turkey
[Laughter]
[Music]
sandwiches it's been 2 weeks since her
surgery and Sammy the timna African gray
waits to have her stitches removed you
ready for bed M and learn the results of
her biopsy I got the biopsy results back
for Sammy and it is cancer
it's a quite aggressive type of cancer
called squil carcinoma which I don't
think I was actually expecting that
particular tumor let me see you girly
girl before I tell Samy's mom the news
of the tumor I really want to take a
look at Sam's incision because if
everything looks perfect then maybe that
makes us feel even better that we got
the whole
tumor hm has like a little scab over it
typically whenever I look at an incision
posttop I'm just seeing the skin edges
heal together and then the remaining
stitches just overlying it but in sami's
case I'm definitely seeing right smack
dab in the middle of the incision it's
having this excessive proliferation of
scabs almost and it just doesn't look
normal the worst case scenario in
something I'm pretty worried about is
that maybe there's still a little bit of
tumor cells there and it's already
starting to grow back I'm not touch
again not going to touch it again that's
it we did it we did it there's your mom
I know okay okay well I do have some
news I did get the pathology report back
and unfortunately it was a tumor it was
a tumor yep it's a type of tumor called
squel carcinoma you you might have heard
of it people can get it um like on their
skin um so an animals so the good thing
about it being the sisal carcinoma is it
usually does not
metastasize meaning it doesn't spread
yeah now the bad thing is is that
sometimes it's really hard to to get um
the whole thing now I'm hoping
surgically we got the entire thing and
this won't come back however we need to
keep a very close eye on that spot I'm
probably going to have you come back
monthly for a while that'll be fine just
to have me look at this feel it real
well see what we can do now
today I can take the stitches out today
so she's not going to like it but I'm
going to steal her one more time
huh be right back
M I know that cancer is a really scary
word to hear and so I can only imagine
what she's going through right
now see I've had her 28 years
so it's
hard was
it
no poor
baby she's a whole lot braver than I
am I'm just taking these sutures out and
there's this like crust over this
incision and I'm worried it's because
like maybe the tumor's coming back is my
biggest
fear well she's going to be all right it
be like losing a child you know if if
anything were to happen to her I I
couldn't I couldn't bear
it hi so she did good I was able to um
take out all the stitches and take off
those scabs now worst case scenario is
that is regrowth already of the tumor at
that site yeah um so I thought we' just
come back in a week yeah take a look at
the incision one week yeah I felt awful
having to tell Samy's mom that it was
cancer
um and even more awful having to tell
her that the decision doesn't look
perfect so I'm a little bit more
concerned I know how much Samy means to
her and I really felt like we fixed her
and now I'm not sure oh we ready to go a
I think she'll be
okay I we just just come back until the
doctor says I don't need to bring her
back
anymore if she wants to see her every
day I'll bring her back I don't
care good
morning no it was bring their dog to
work and I decided I was going to bring
a chicken inste which one is this this
is Payway
Payway she was waiting at the car I just
threw in the car Payway the chicken
decided to Ride Along to the clinic
today to help deliver news about another
pet of a foul
variety Jim the turkey and his attacks
on Dr Mel Med's
husband oh yeah how's old Jim Jim I
would say that he has gotten somewhat
how's your husband doing
dangerous okay so watch him see he's
doing The Sing Off and puffing up
himself and they M Their Manners look at
them one day I was watching him him and
I said to him I said you got to act like
a male turkey and get square and get big
and so we did that and now he can back
them off I'm just body language wow I'm
really impressed when I first met Jim at
Dr melman's house he was launching
himself at Dr melin's husband David but
now David's kind of learned to Puff
himself up like this male turkey and
Jim's really learned to back off now
here he is eating there's Payway there's
PayWay
but um but he can they'll eat from him
and they'll be you know oh that's good
at least it's better I don't know if it
was the implant that gave Jim to
moderate his testosterone or if it's
David's behavior modification that's
doing the trick but either way I'm
thrilled it's working out tell your
husband He's a brave man and keep it up
St David that's right what a wonderful
man to work with the
turkeys
[Music]
Sammy the timna African gray is back to
have her surgical incision
checked hello good morning good morning
how are you I'm good how's our Sammy we
had to come in today to get her checked
up make sure that's healing up good and
of course I've been doctoring it twice a
day ever since she uh had stitches taken
out if sami's incision is finally
healing that could mean no cancer cells
were left behind during the surgery and
Sammy could be cancer-free
the silver lining of this particular
type of tumor is that it's just going to
be at that sight it doesn't typically
spread to other parts of the body so
there is some good hope that hopefully
surgery is actually Curative and if we
got really good margins it won't come
back come here all right well I just
really am very curious to see how this
looks what a good
Sammy oh my goodness helicop this bird
is look how good this bird
is hello my love how are you can I see
your little neckie
huh oh my God that looks
awesome it's perfect I mean really look
at it look I don't even know where I did
the surgery I can't find where you did I
can't find where I did the surgery the
right time to put ey dine on I just swab
oh this
great I'm taking a look at Sam's
incision and I can't even find it I mean
it just looks so great
wow the skin is completely healed
together there's even new feathers
growing over the area oh my goodness I
know I'm very like I'm really paranoid
about how cosmetic it is if she still
had the tumor the incision probably
still would look like it's not healing
or I would start to see a mask going up
underneath that skin which in her case
I'm not seeing either I'm seeing
perfectly beautiful skin no nodule
underneath I really think 99% positive
the cancer is completely gone and
hopefully to never return again I'm
proud of you you did a good work that is
just awesome isn't it Sammy there you go
go to your mom oh I am so happy so
leaved because well I've had her for 28
years and it would just break my heart
if anything happened to her ready to go
home all right honey I won't see you
anytime soon which is a good thing
okay say good yeah I'll miss you a
little bit but that's okay you'll be
good I'm just so excited to finally be
able to deliver great news to this
client I mean this bird is her as her
baby she loves Sammy so much thanks guys
bye
she
saved it looks so good I'm so happy that
Bird's so
[Music]
precious